desde hace varias semanas la región del
donbass en el este de ucrania es el
objetivo militar de vladimir putin tras
fracasar en la toma de kiev y en las
principales ciudades del norte es aquí
donde el ejército ruso enfocó su
atención afirmando que su objetivo era
liberar el corazón industrial después de
capturar severodonezk la última
conquista de moscú es lysychansk y tras
tomar la ciudad clave el ministerio de
defensa ruso afirma que toda la región
de lugansk está bajo su control según el
gobernador de la región el próximo
objetivo de moscú no es otro que la
vecina provincia de donges
había un riesgo de ser cercados en lista
chance las unidades que estaban allí
podrían continuar controlando los
territorios por una dos o tres semanas
más pero la pregunta era cuál era el
precio de esta acción
preferíamos sufrir solos los bombardeos
a larga distancia de la artillería en
misiles y ataques aéreos que intentaban
derrotarlos entonces los soldados
perderían la vida por nada podría ser un
segundo mariupol es por eso que
finalmente se tomó la decisión de
retirar las fuerzas del isi changin y
murió
en lugar y donde viven los separatistas
apoyados por moscú que luchan contra
ucrania desde 2014 justo antes de que
comenzara la guerra vladimir putin
también reconoció la independencia de
las dos regiones y dice que dará el
territorio capturado a la república
popular de lugansk pero asegura que la
lucha debe continuar
las unidades militares incluyendo el
grupo oriental y el grupo occidental
deben llevar a cabo sus tareas de
acuerdo con los planes previamente
aprobados espero que todo continúe en su
dirección de la misma manera que ocurrió
en lugansk hasta ahora
el presidente de ucrania dice que las
tropas rusas han acumulado ya su mayor
potencia de fuego en el donbass capaz de
disparar decenas de miles de proyectiles
de artillería al día y ha prometido
recuperar el territorio perdido
utilizando armas de fuego de largo
alcance donadas por occidente pero queda
la duda si podrán detener el avance ruso